[Musique]
jamais on aurait cru autant parler de ce
serment au roi Christian Dufour José
Legault Michel Saugier est en route de
par la voix des des ondes on va il va
être avec nous dans quelques secondes
bonsoir Michel vous êtes bonsoir Paul
Saint-Pierre flamandon vient de nous
dire parce que là il est en train de
jouer une partie hier c'est intéressant
Christian vous dit il faut qu'il se
laisse une porte de sortie pour entrer
ne serait-ce que quelques semaines en
attendant le projet de loi le dos disait
non non il fait bien de se tenir debout
le Québec solidaire aujourd'hui n'a pas
prêté serment au roi en disant il y a
des négociations au cours des prochaines
semaines qui vont s'engager puis on
verra ce qu'on fait ce qu'on entre mais
pspp je vous le fait entendre si vous
étiez pas avec nous
n'exclut plus rien n'exclut pas d'entrer
donc et peut-être le faire
en secret en cachette le serment pour
ensuite l'annuler avec une loi on écoute
s'il y a quelques minutes à l'émission
le chef de Québec solidaire n'exclut pas
aujourd'hui d'entrer à l'intérieur pour
débattre un projet de loi est-ce que
vous excluez d'entrer à l'intérieur pour
rien exclure puisque tellement des
certitudes il y a tellement
d'incertitude mais je réitère ma volonté
très sincère et senti mais vous ne devez
pas d'entrée
alors on le voit à pied et il est sur ce
cheval là et là Québec solidaire
d'ailleurs qui a la dernière fois ils
avaient Michel si je commence avec vous
ils avaient fait ça en pas publique
parce qu'il trouvait que c'était une
honte de devoir faire ça à la reine à
l'époque là ils ne l'ont pas fait alors
il a quand même mis ce sujet là sur la
table Michel c'est ça va où croyez-vous
à partir du moment où le gouvernement à
partir du moment où monsieur Legault
dis-moi le j'en ai rien à tirer du
serment à Sa Majesté le Roi sa règle une
grande partie du problème c'est ça qui
peut y avoir un projet de loi ça prend
ça ça prend pas juste une motion ça peut
c'est un projet de loi qui va abolir le
serment à la reine en prenant pour
acquis que c'est une partie de la
constitution interne du Québec que je
peux rentrer dans les détails mais c'est
pas juste c'est pas juste la
construction fédérale c'est la
construction du Québec donc on peut le
demander à partir de ce moment-là
c'est Monsieur Saint-Pierre palmoron
doit rester dehors avec ces deux
collègues le jour où il y a le projet de
l'homme qui veut être là
en sachant que c'est toi sincèrement qui
va tomber on relève de la minutie du
détail à la fin la décision la décision
est simple on est dans les séances
José oui parce que si jamais le
gouvernement répète que ça prend une loi
non parce que ce que souhaitait ce que
souhaite toujours monsieur Paul
Saint-Pierre flamandon c'est de dire
faites une motion nous on va attendre à
l'extérieur voir des caméras une fois
que la motion va être adoptée on va
rentrer et puis ça va être tambour etc
or le gouvernement dit ça prend une loi
alors rend le dilemme qu'il a c'est ce
que je rentre pour débattre la loi où
j'attends des semaines dehors
mais je pense pas qu'il va attendre des
semaines je pense pas que jamais eu
l'intention non plus d'attendre des
semaines écouter monsieur Saint-Pierre
Plamondon s'est battu becquet ongles
pour être dispute il y a deux autres
députés c'est très très précieux là non
moi je persiste je persiste les signes
je pense qu'on a 6 à une stratégie
extrêmement habile une stratégie des
petits pas et le chef d'orchestre c'est
Monsieur saint-pierre-flamondon depuis
le début il a réussi évidemment à
s'assurer une visibilité médiatique
exceptionnelle pendant que le premier
ministre est occupé à préparer son
conseil des ministres mais il le fait là
où c'est vraiment habile c'est qu'il le
fait sur une sur une question de
conviction c'est c'est pas un chef
politique qui me rendit c'est vraiment
une conviction et c'est une conviction
qui donne la chance de partager avec le
chef de Québec solidaire et et les 11
élus de Québec solidaire donc là on voit
que dans cette stratégie à petits pas
comme Monsieur secteur comme tout le
monde Québec solidaire avait déposé un
projet de loi en un sens là il y a
quelques années qu'il allait s'en faire
un allié et en effet c'est devenu un
avis on voit même si Gabriel ado Dubois
qui dit eh c'est nous en premier
pour la paternité ou la
je pense que l'objectif c'était vraiment
d'amener ce sujet là d'occuper de
terrain politique et médiatique et tout
ça est réussi et là je pense que la
personne qui va être vraiment piégée par
ça en bout de piste c'est Dominique
Anglade la chef du Parti libéral parce
que elle elle va devoir prendre position
parce que c'est une invitation par les
deux chefs très très minoritaires
de se rencontrer tout le monde et de
trouver une solution une voix de passage
transpartisane madame Anglade si elle
tourne le dos à ça à risque d'avoir un
problème avec le peu d'électeurs
francophones qui lui reste mais pourquoi
tournerait-elle m'a fait à l'époque ils
avaient vous avez raison de souvenir
mais je crois Christian d'abord hier
vous disiez il faut qu'il se ménage une
porte de là une petite porte de sortie
pour entrer quelques semaines en
attendant une loi mais effectivement on
doit reconnaître que objectivement il a
réussi à imposer un débat en changer les
termes depuis quelques semaines il a
réussi à revitaliser
l'électro-ouvrezieux ça me fera plaisir
toute énervés puis en plus c'est vrai
qu'il y a occupé en fait l'espace
médiatique mais il doit vraiment
vraiment beaucoup de reconnaissance au
Québec solidaire qui le sortit du trou
c'est tout d'un paradoxe parce que
Québec solidaire c'est un parti qu'on va
comme rigide d'habitude alors dans ce
dossier là c'est un parti qui est plus
coulant et dans l'entrevue que Paul
Saint-Pierre timbeno vous a donné tantôt
là il est plus coulant là il y a le mec
qui peut avoir une porte de sortie et
tant mieux pour lui moi je trouve ce que
je trouve très très intéressant ce qui
se passait actuellement et ça illustre
ce qui écrivait Eric Montigny après
l'érection disant qu'on va assister à un
alignement du système partisan québécois
entre autres à la suite de notre mode de
scrutin qui était implacable pour les
petits partis s'ils veulent exercer du
poids là on voit une coordination de
Québec solidaire et du PQ dans ce
dossier là pour exercer du pouvoir et ça
c'est très sain et ça c'est très nouveau
là de
tout le monde sait qu'à Québec solidaire
on n'est pas des grands partisans de la
monarchie c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est comme ça depuis notre
fondation serment la Couronne
britannique c'est une pratique coloniale
archaïque dépassé je veux rappeler qu'en
2018 les 10 députés solidaires avaient
tenté en vain de ne pas prêter serment à
la reine moi je crois au dialogue je
crois qu'on est capable de s'entendre on
a un mois pour le faire pour permettre à
tout le monde de sier le 29 novembre
dans le respect de sa liberté de compte
l'Assemblée nationale a le droit de
décider comment ils veulent
organiser leur processus
d'asserrementation ça prend un projet de
loi mais pour ça ça prend des députés
qui siègent qui votent sur les projets
doigts mais je vais laisser ceux qui se
sont faites lire à l'Assemblée nationale
de prendre des décisions sur comment ils
vont faire leur processus je peux vous
dire qu'ici à la Chambre des communes on
a aucunement l'intention de changer
changer les les assermentations
il y a deux écoles là-dessus il y en a
qui disent le serment fait partie de la
Constitution du Canada ça prend un
abonnement constitutionnel canadien il y
en a d'autres qui disent écouteurs le
Conseil législatif on devrait être
capable d'abolir de serment là c'est la
condition interne du Québec alors là je
rentrerai pas là-dedans mais je voudrais
souligner une chose parce que ça arrive
très rarement certainement d'accord
la semaine dernière j'écrivais justement
que n'aurait pas le choix que de
travailler ensemble un certain nombre de
dossiers sans parler nécessairement une
convergence parce qu'on en voit une
première manifestation mais
contrairement à Christian a tout respect
moi je ne pense pas que Monsieur Nadou
Dubois a sorti monsieur
saint-pierre-flammondon du trou bien au
contraire je pense que c'était évident
tout ça ça fait partie de la stratégie à
petit pas on sait que Québec solidaire
était pour donc c'était clair qu'ils
allaient se joindre cela étant dit c'est
quand même intéressant de voir ces deux
jeunes chefs de parties
être capable de faire de la politique en
bon prince être capable de faire avec
une grande maturité aussi sur la place
publique justement cette fameuse
politique autrement donc pspp essaie de
faire mon depuis le début on dirait que
c'est un petit peu contagieux maintenant
du côté de Québec solidaire ce qui est
excellent et encore une fois moi je
pense que ce qui va vraiment être
intéressant c'est que va faire Dominique
réglable avec ce dossier est-ce que je
peux ajouter quand même conclusion
ils peuvent surfer deux trois semaines
là-dessus mais pour la population
générale le 6 ça dure plus longtemps que
ça les gens vont trouver qui sont très
très déconnectés de la réalité là
le sermentations là c'est quelque chose
de formel qui est superficielle quelque
part donc là en fait du millage mais il
faut qu'il se contrôle il faut qu'il
règle ça parce que les gens vont les
laisser tomber
péremption c'est la convocation de
l'Assemblée nationale le 29 novembre
il va falloir non mais je dis que c'est
la date finale alors d'ici là il est
parti peuvent trouver une solution pour
s'entendre ça je pense l'opinion
politique québécoise et majoritairement
favorable à ça et je pense que ce serait
très mal vu si notre perception le temps
que les dernières feuilles tombent il
faut que ça soit réglé ok justement vous
parliez de réalignements Christian des
des forces politiques sur dans la joute
politique du Québec compte tenu notre
mode de scrutin
il y en a
Eric dumer aujourd'hui qui a dit écoutez
les amis là il y a 500 000 personnes qui
ont voté pour moi puis je ne peux même
ma carte d'accès à la semelle nationale
et périmée je peux plus entrer faire des
points de presse parce que je n'ai pas
de député élu on va l'écouter puis on
revient tout de suite
monsieur le gosse il décide la
démocratie c'est important puisque 530
000 Québécois ça vaut rien pour lui il
va subir les conséquences de ses actes
s'il pense que c'est dehors c'est ici
qu'il faut manifester qu'il faut sortir
dans la rue parce qu'il y a pas de place
pour lui parce qu'il est pas assez
démocrate pour nous laisser entrer à
l'Assemblée nationale mais il subira les
conséquences de ces décisions
alors question toute simple qui
peut le faire entrer lui voudrait un
arrangement pour pouvoir par exemple
donner des conférences de presse à
l'intérieur des murs même s'il n'a pas
d'élus etc il veut un aménagement pour
que pour qu'elle voit entendue Christian
vous êtes d'accord je vous parlais je
vais vous donner la parole après mais
José est-ce que c'est quelque chose de
possible ça
politiquement
raisonnable dans les faits bon c'est et
dans la mesure où le Premier ministre
refuse maintenant de réformer le mode de
scrutin mais c'est sûr que il pourra pas
se contenter seulement de dire à
m'amener on va faire une réforme
parlementaire bon il va y avoir tout le
débat autour du statut aussi du
Québécois de Québec solidaire laquelle
statue parlementaire ils vont avoir
quelles sont tes budget etc monsieur dum
à part le fait que c'est pas très habile
de partir sa négociation avec une menace
là mais bon enfin ça c'est son style
populiste mais c'est clair que sans
réforme de mode de scrutin on les
condamné enfin les élus sont condamnés à
trouver des aménagements et des
accompagnements
pas au Salon bleu mais Michel
une petite carte aspire plutôt inspire
la petite carte serait facile à lui
donner c'est à dire que derrière
l'édifice du Parlement
le lieutenant gouverneur et la tribune
de la presse qu'on lui donne accès à
cette salle-là pour faire des
conférences de presse et Paul le
Parlement parce que au début mais quand
au menaces au Premier ministre je serai
tenter de dire à vos pensées pour
spothalock parce qu'à un moment donné il
n'a pas fait lire personne et ça dans le
système ça veut dire quelque chose ça
aussi alors moi je suis pour lui donner
un accès certain accès c'est sûr comme
comme bien d'autres groupes dans la
société mais pas pour le Salon bleu
parce que
l'offre de 5 parties reste deux trois
élections c'est ce qu'on ce qui est
peut-être une période transit ça si ça
perdue
il va falloir créer des aménagements il
faut qu'on repense nos choses
christianes oui c'est clair d'accord
avec mes deux collègues
Eric John doit faire très attention à
son temps et puis que les menaces n'ont
pas leur place surtout que depuis
l'élection il y a un certain sympathies
nouvelles pour iridium qui était le
grand perdant en fait de l'élection de
notre système électorale
fondamentalement il a raison je pense
que Monsieur Lego en fait qui est
probablement tenté par la toute
puissance là il faut qu'il réatérise
puis il faut qu'il consomme des
aménagements sinon ça devient très
malsain c'est vrai que eridium il
représente 530 000 personnes parmi ces
citoyens il y a des gens qui sont
frustrés et c'est possible d'aménager il
faut que le premier ministre c'est lui
qui a le contrôle il faut que le premier
ministre lui tende la main concentre des
aménagements si jamais sa première
réaction a été peut-être que c'était
rancunier parce que iridium a été le
critique plus dur de sa gestion
sanitaire on peut le comprendre ça
première réaction a été celle d'une
fermeture totale parce qu'il me frappe
c'est que il se positionne sont en train
d'essayer de se réorganiser suite à
l'élection c'est comme si monsieur
Legault en fait sous-traiter en fait la
gestion de chat Dominique anglaise en
fait que le mauvais rôle mais reste que
c'est le premier ministre que le pouvoir
là-dedans il faut qu'il envoie des
messages plus d'ouverture au parti
d'opposition pour que le système
fonctionne il faut une réforme
parlementaire c'est clair dans la mesure
où Monsieur le goût a fermé complètement
la forme la porte à la réforme du mode
scrutin je pleurais pas là-dessus vous
le savez il est condamné à commander
mais par contre Eric James il faut que
ça sa tension il y a un tank qui passe
on dit au Québec là il y a un temps les
menaces ne passent pas plus il y a une
nouvelle sympathie faudrait pas qu'il la
perte cette sympathie bon José est-ce
que ça revient au Premier ministre ou à
l'ensemble des chefs de parties de
trouver un aménagement d'aller voir les
buts les gens de l'Assemblée nationale
parce que Madame anglaise on parle
d'autre chose on parle de la
reconnaissance de ceux qui ont peu
d'élus mais lui duel mais dans une autre
catégorie là José c'est c'est ça bon
alors on va avoir éventuellement un
président de l'Assemblée nationale le
bureau de l'Assemblée nationale va se
reconstituer alors oui bien sûr ça va
être aux élus au bureau à décider du
sort si je puis dire des rituels mais et
encore une fois je pense que sur le plan
politique de faire des menaces en même
temps qu'on a commission d'enquête à
Ottawa sur le soi-disant qu'on voit de
la liberté qui est très très mauvais
souvenir je pense que aussi sont sont
sur mon mal choisi pour brandir cette
menace là il est pas très bon
j'ai envoyé un autre message ce qu'on a
à l'extrait je pense qu'on a l'extrait
sur les âmes sur le goût il a dit
quelque chose qui n'arrivera pas là mais
il a dit ne dépassez pas 20 ministres ce
qu'on a l'extrait oui c'est bon
monsieur le gosse il décide la
démocratie c'est important puisque 530
000 Québécois ça vaut rien pour lui il
va subir les conséquences de ses actes
s'il pense que c'est dehors c'est ici
qu'il faut manifester puisqu'il faut
sortir dans la rue parce qu'il y a pas
de place pour lui parce qu'il est pas
assez démocrate pour nous laisser entrer
à l'Assemblée nationale mais il subira
les conséquences de ces décisions
je suis désolé là on a fait on a répété
la malle même extrait c'est pas celui-là
mais il disait dans l'autre extrait là
qui donne pas des limousines à plus que
20 personnes s'il vous plaît ça ça
n'arrive Christian tour de table dernier
tour de table moi je trouve ça ça montre
que ils ont un rôle à jouer c'est très
juste ce message là parce que est-ce que
Monsieur Lego va céder à la facilité là
évidemment il triple il y a c'est 90
députés c'est lui qui contrôle tout
c'est en temps de faire un gros
gouvernement ça serait céder à la
question de pas besoin de gouvernement
on a besoin de ministres efficace et
réduire mais il fait bien de dire ces
choses-là Michel
il y a quand même un certain nombre de
ministères qui en plus que 20 au Québec
alors donc il faut éliminer
ça c'est encore une fois de l'espace de
Monsieur duem on est capable de faire ça
le Premier ministre tout ça juste la
santé on appelle ça pour rien peut-être
que besoin de
la santé et puis il y a d'autres il y a
d'autres endroits aussi on crée un trou
de pouvoir à Monsieur Flint par exemple
ben ça veut dire qu'il faut
José ouais c'est ça écoutait ça aussi
c'est du populisme
plus d'argent dans les poches des
contribuables écoutez
un moment donné aussi à réduire son
conseil des ministres justement le sous
pression ça a été un fiasco comme il
disait Michel C ça prend un certain
nombre de ministres qu'est-ce que vous
voulez le Québec est une société
extrêmement bureaucrative
et on a un état avec des services aussi
certains services que d'autres provinces
n'ont pas donc sans aller vers l'extrême
de Bern braderie en 2003 avec plus de 30
ministres
32 c'est sorti alors 27 28 là ça devient
un message qui est envoyé quand même par
le nombre de ministres moi j'ai
travaillé dans la fonction publique et
puis les fonctionnaires c'est eux qui
payent le prix de ces super
gouvernements-là parce qu'on s'enlise
dans la société
très bien merci beaucoup c'est demain
13h qu'on aura le début de la réponse de
ça émission spéciale 13h demain avec
tous nos camarades de Québec de la salle
des nouvelles on va suivre l'entrée des
futurs nouveaux ministres de ce
gouvernement de François Legault merci
beaucoup à vous trois bonne soirée au
revoir bonsoir bonsoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI